you know you talk about how important
chemistry is and I know is the band a
democracy you know does everyone have a
voting say I think that this is very
hard to answer objectively but I'll try
okay I think the five of us because
there's four four that you see myself
Johnny on guitar guy plays bass will
who's the drummer simulator and then
Phil who is um
are kind of creative director he you've
known him since we were 13 yeah
and he was the other person where I grew
up who was like we're going to do this
and we would read books about REM and
you two and the police and we were both
in a blues band with this slightly older
kid who was teaching us about Motown
that's what we're going to do but with
no real
belief no real
knowledge of how
so
for whatever reason we've all got our
gifts in the world and mine is I get
sent songs and I get
a very clear idea of how we're supposed
to where we're supposed to go as a band
and I get sent ideas all the time for
this and this and this and this and this
and this
and
so and Phil does too in a different way
for more sort of where we should play or
uh let's release an album then or
something like that so to counterbalance
that you have will and Guy
who we're not talking about music we're
just talking about how the band operates
they are more of the naysayers in a good
way to make sure we don't do all the
stupid ideas but they sort of pick what
actually is good
and that's the same with music except
that on all of our songs I know this is
a long-winded answer no this is this is
when all of our songs there like a
production line mostly which is that I
get sent sort of the skeleton of the
song
and the title and everything and I'll
present that and then Johnny go and
we'll we'll layer up their stuff on it
and it's not finished until they've all
either put their parts on it or decided
not to so we we always split our
publishing royalties
Whatever the song is because
it allows people to choose what's best
for the song because they're going to
get paid either way so they might say
this doesn't need any drums on it but
I'll still get paid for drumming so I
don't need to put drums on it does that
make sense it makes perfect sense
um and I'm down with it except for the
payment thing I do my best to screw the
people around me I can see that from the
from the threadbare Footwear hi I keep
saying that's my name up on the Marquee
and then I hand them a a can of uh old
beans and they can have that no it is
first of all I think that's that very
admirable but it's also it's smart
because it means I I think there are
bands and you two comes to mind that
have endured for a very long time
because there's a communal sense in the
band and I think that helps a band last
longer I think you two have probably
have a slightly different but as
powerful or more powerful democracy
because they I think they write slightly
differently them and REM were the two
that we look to in terms of how you keep
the band together yeah by sharing credit
and money and that's really proved to be
true it's funny your job starts out to
make music and then this other job comes
along and some people can do it and some
can't and in your case obviously you you
You're great at it but the stage work of
doing a massive concert right the things
all those skills are not discussed in
the in the entire process of you
learning to play music and play music
with your friends and write these songs
there's
no discussion or thought about okay when
we're playing the arena when we're
playing the Super Bowl how do we put
this across that takes
all of these skills that a lot of people
who could get to the point that you were
at musically would say oh I can't do
that but you are very Adept at it and I
think that's a whole other skill set
well first of all thanks Conan I I don't
know how to answer something like that
in terms of adeptitude is that the right
word aptitude okay get that in yeah
I I this is another place where I feel
that
we've leaned into being ourselves with
no fear of embarrassment because there's
no way I'm as Adept on stage as Beyonce
or Mick Jagger
uh but I'm definitely the best at being
me right so that you can only kind of
learn by doing yes and by loving and I
guess what I'm saying is Chris you put
on a show yeah we do you and and you and
and and and the rest of the guys you put
on a show but you are uh you know
burning incredible amount of calories uh
there's there's a there's a huge you're
giving of yourself and you're also
playing to a massive massive uh group of
people and a lot of thought goes into
the live show yeah because it it seems
very important to you and the guys that
everybody feel and be part of every
moment yeah definitely I was thinking
the other day that a lot of the things
that we're really good at as a band are
not
um categories to get bands get measured
by so we might not be the best this or
that or in the top 100 this or that
magazine whatever but there are some
things we really care about that we're
just never assessed for
and the main thing we care about is
that interaction and communication
partly for our own
say because humans wanting to feel alive
and yeah not so alone and sort of sing
together and feel that positivity
and partly if for our audience so that
they can have a great time more so than
ever that's our priority
um
so I forget what the question was I'm so
sorry I asked you how the first world
war started yeah well a bit like that
hahaha